welcome back everyone this is the
Ferrowind keynote and I'm Dana
today I want to talk about where
our robots are going next year
um so first the numbers
we shipped twelve hundred robots last
year and this year we will ship
ten thousand of them for sure
the new factory in Monterrey is
probably going to open by the middle
of next year if the permits come through
and I think the F3 will be the
first robot you can buy for your home
it won't be cheap at first uh
maybe twenty thousand dollars
but the price will come down fast
we are not going to raise prices
on existing customers ever [Music]
thanks for listening and see you
at developer day in March